why do you think it's been this long
without a black lead in the male
bachelor franchise why has it been this
long yeah
and I want to make it clear I say black
because I'm black you know I would like
to see you know like well there have
been Latinos in the lead but you know
Asian Indian I have people reaching out
to me from all backgrounds ethnicities
that are saying they would like to see
it and I think that's the movement that
you see going on right now with the
hashtag bi POC Bachelor I honestly think
that it's the show is a business it's a
franchise and there's a quote that I use
in my blog post that acknowledges that I
the the franchise has been around for 18
years they're a well-run machine they
know exactly what they're doing and part
of a business is giving you know it's
supply and demand it's giving them what
the supply that they want whether
they're demanding and I think they know
what they're on who their audience is
and what they want and so they're giving
them the product that they want which
are white leads and I don't think that
they've shied away from that at this
point you talk about you know you
wanting to stick with the franchise
because you saw and I remember you
telling me this when I interviewed you
on your photo shoot years ago you said
that I'm worried about this but at the
same time I know that I have to do this
I know this is an opportunity and now
you've stuck with the franchise since
then and you talk about trying to push
in from the inside for change
I wondered what conversations you've had
what has it been like being somebody who
now has the podcast and who's been on
the show for reunions and for the the
panel on Peter season what conversations
have you had with the producers behind
the scenes about affecting this change
yeah I mean I've always been very vocal
and I will say that when I was leave
they did make changes you know they
brought in producers of color that they
didn't work with me but they worked with
my contestants and I noticed that they
asked me a lot of questions because they
wanted to do things right because it was
the first time but after I was the lead
those changes went away
and you only have one black producer
that's
the house with the contestants and there
were three when I was there and so I
think that not I think but to answer
your question about in regards to have I
had these conversations absolutely you
know I definitely talk to them about
when are you going to have a lead of
color you know that you have had several
good candidates I named them out in my
block ocn Taoiseach Mike Johnson
you know before your excuses used to be
they don't make it far enough you don't
have you know certain people trying out
for the show I've spoken to them about
the lack of minorities that try out to
the show and now you're getting that so
now what's the issue you know and I
think it goes back to the business of it
all but I've definitely had the
conversations about having a lead of
color what that looks like
and making those changes I since I
stepped away from the show I'll be
honest I haven't really talked to them
about the internal changes I've more so
been vocal about having a lead of color
and what's the response that you get
when you say those things to the
higher-ups that they want the everybody
wants diversity it's just it doesn't
work out it's kind of the answer that
I'm given we all want this to happen
it's just for one reason or another it
doesn't happen there's always and I
think that's where I get fed up because
it's like okay well it used to be well
they weren't going far enough well now
they are going far enough so now what is
it and I've even heard interviews given
where it's it's been referenced that you
know they want it to be it doesn't have
to be based on their color it's just
having the right person well I'm not
quite sure what that is because we've
you know little we hit we can't have the
perfect bachelor or bachelorette and in
the past few seasons they haven't been
stellar I guess that's the best word
that I can use and so I'm just not sure
that what we're measuring it against as
far as what makes a good lead I mean
look at the Mike Johnson conversation I
think is the one p you hear from people
the loudest
I was watching hannasseys and I was
watching human and saying Mike for
bachelor this guy's great and then the
conversation started to change and to be
honest I think it's hard because then
when Peters named Peter is half Latino
and so you think okay well this is this
is something but if you get specifically
into those I wasn't Mike Johnson The
Bachelor did you ask that question did
anybody have a good answer for you
behind the scenes on that well I've had
a good answer for me and I would also
have to clarify that Pete you know Juan
Pablo and Peter are Latino but they're
white Hispanic right they're races white
we haven't had one a person of color we
haven't had a black lead but I
definitely asked I was extremely vocal
about Mike Johnson and how he checked
all the boxes and it doesn't make sense
why he has not believed and even it
seemed as if the audience wanted him
the audience was my into Peter and
that's my also argument about the show
can make you fall in love with anyone
you know people weren't receptive to
Hannah brown then they loved her she's
the most popular by social media
standards in regards to the Bachelorette
Peter same thing they didn't love him so
I just I don't know why it wasn't like
Johnson I don't know why I wasn't seeing
she's a yellow graduate beautiful
Taoiseach stunning made it to the top
three why aren't these people Eric made
it to the top three on my season you
know it just it all goes back to me to
the same thing you're just giving the
audience what they're comfortable with
and that's why I thought your blog post
was helpful with laying things out but
you know people say The Bachelor and
it's this it's an entity it's so many
people working at so many different
levels and so I think there and there's
also a lot of behind the scenes of how
these people are chosen which i think is
helpful to have someone try to walk us
through I I wonder too you know you said
that if this doesn't change you plan to
disassociate from the franchise you and
Becca kufran have that podcast Bachelor
happy hour that that is through Warner
Brothers what does that actually look
like I don't know if you're under
contract does that look like you
officially stepping away and is that
happening soon if
your if that you don't hear from them
what are those conversations right now
yeah I I am under contract right now so
I'm not quite sure how that's going to
work but I'm serious I it's more of when
I say I'm stepping away yes I've said
I'm stepping away because I'm
embarrassed and I just don't want to be
affiliated with in these times right now
I feel like we all are self reflecting
on have you been an ally what what are
you affiliated with that is part of the
problem you know different you know
you're just you're just looking within
during these times and as I look with
then I look at my affiliation with the
Batchelor franchise and what's wrong and
I did find it frustrating I got a lot of
negative feedback where there were those
who maybe are new to following me that
are saying why are you just now saying
something which is why my article I laid
out I've always been extremely vocal and
it hasn't always been well-received
now it's we're living in different times
so it's received in a different way but
I don't want to be affiliated with a
franchise who's not on the right side of
this at this time at this point you
can't be neutral you're either on the
wrong side or the right side and the
franchise to me has been on the wrong
side for 18 years for 40 seasons so are
you going to step onto the right side at
this point and that's what I am trying
to put the pressure on them to do and
hoping also that the audience will as
well I get so many people that write me
that say I feel conflicted watching the
show because I know that they're things
that can be changed well then be the
change start speaking out it can't just
be me they're tired of hearing from me
but then on the other side of it I'm
honestly exhausted Lauren I'm I'm tired
of speaking out there have been issues
that have happened a couple in May with
Hannah Brown and then with Garrett and
I'm just so exhausted from having to
speak out and I and I feel obligated to
because it does directly impact me and
I've also I think built a brand where I
am outspoken on certain things that
bother me or that affect me and
just mentally exhausted and I just feel
for my mental health I might need to
step away as well have you asked for
specific things or have they you know
when you say change is it and look I
know it's not on you to come up with
change of this franchise but just
because you laid that out in your blog I
was wondering have you told them I need
to see these specific things happen for
me to stay I haven't laid it out that
way
the most detailed I've been was in my
blog and that was just more so thinking
it through and writing it out and
processing it I mean it definitely we
need to see a lead of color in the role
for season 25 I said that last year
after Mike Johnson was not cast I was so
I don't think I'm still over that so as
much as I I like Peter he's a delight I
still don't think I've ever Mike Johnson
not being picked as the bastard but I
didn't lay it out that way I think that
if they do decide to make a lead of
color and they are being receptive to
certain things that I wrote in my blog
or even the petition that's being
circulated around which what I saw last
night had over 40,000 signatures that
petition lays out what changes need to
be made as well and I think that if
they're serious about making changes
moving forward they will hire people of
color of all backgrounds to not just
work as producers but maybe as a
consultant as to what they can do
because I think one of the changes that
I would like to see is that there are
internal changes to make excuse me to
make contestants of color feel more
comfortable that's part of the success
of the show if somebody you feel like
you can relate to you can open up with
when you're having those interviews or
items in the house have you heard from
anybody on the executive side the show's
creator and executive producer since the
blog no I haven't heard from anyone in
the past week yes I have heard from an
executive producer just saying that they
they hear me and they want to make
changes
well that feels like it does but this
isn't my first rodeo with carrying an
executive producer say I wanted we want
to make some changes I believe you want
to but all right
used to believe you want to but I'm not
seeing anything I've been affiliated
with strangers for almost four years and
I hear you but I'm not seeing any action
behind those words you mentioned to your
your response when that 2019
Bachelorette reunion was filmed that you
pointed out that you were the only woman
of color in the room and I mean I
remember that that was very striking was
there any productive conversation after
that of hey we hear you you know
that was a loud thing to say that we
needed to hear and here's what we're
doing from here yeah I mean it was not
here's what we're doing from here but I
I was actually emotional I don't even
think I've ever talked about this I was
emotional the day of the 15 year reunion
because I felt so out of place and and
it's not that the girls weren't
welcoming I mean we have a group chat we
talk all the time we've had snooze
during quarantine I glad that I went
because it really it was really great to
meet bachelorettes I hadn't before and
to create the sisterhood but it was
emotional for me I remember they had to
redo my makeup because I was just kind
of like this is so sad that one one out
of fifteen even but Hannah wasn't there
one out of fifteen and it just was so it
just hit me in a certain way to realize
this is what the franchise's this is
representative of the franchise I'm
affiliated with and I don't know if any
changes being made to try to change this
so I I have spoken with producers and I
did after that and then of course it was
we want to do better
we want more leaves of color but then no
action has been taken
sorry I got a little I I hate hear you
say that I hate bringing you say that
you um that you were emotional that day
because it's I think just you know I I
interviewed you on that date on Nick's
season on
one on one and then like to watch you
blossom the way that you have and do all
this in your career it's been really
great to see and so I hate hearing you
say that that day was behind the scenes
what it was for you um you remember
hiking Moreland's remember I just
couldn't believe I had a one on one day
pass the world was at my feet I was so
excited and I just thought you know
moving forward I was just getting a
one-on-one I didn't know much but
they're like oh you got a one-on-one
that's big oh you got first impression
that's huge I thought oh if maybe this
relationship with Nick will work or I'll
go far being representation for a black
woman and who knows where I could go
from here I have so much hope I remember
that interview very well
I was sweating it was good oh I remember
that girl and then to see where I am now
it's just so sad what can happen in four
years when nothing is done when no
changes are made I'm not hopeful at all
by any means and I think that I'm
justified in that and seeing how things
have gone down in the last four years
but now it's so interesting you brought
that up because I remember that girl and
now I'm a bit jaded it's tough because
you're stuck in between two worlds you
know I I want to be hopeful but then I
also you know my dad always says history
has predicted values so I'm holding on
to that but nothing has been done in the
past but it's the messages that I get I
have so many people that reach out to me
that are like keep going thank you for
standing up you know I as a woman of
color I've watched this show for years
and it's so nice to have representation
and that you speak for us that is what
keeps me going that's what keeps me
wanting to fight for change and maybe
I'm not hopeful but at least I'm still
fighting for those who are
[Music]